donc on prend des risques qui sont
colossaux pour dépenser l'argent public
pour que les sites précités soit plus
cher donc avec qui expliquez-nous il
réellement
on va points donc qu'est ce que c'est
que ces débats où on est on laisse
parler les promoteurs pendant des heures
et à la fin ceux qui décident de
continuer pas est ce que c'est encore
une démocratie
j'en doute de plus en plus ce sens
[Musique]
découvert que l'énergie nucléaire c'est
une énergie qui était déjà très
décarbonée ou est-ce qu'on veut apporter
enfin mettre en place des énergies plus
polluantes
lorsqu'il faut juste pas dire la vérité
est que l'énergie éolienne ne sait pas
forcément ceux qu'on croise un peu une
énergie verte plus les câbles sont longs
et plus une énergie est perdu et coup
c'est compliqué
[Musique]
où
donc les échecs cumulés en fête du
battage de pieux du bétonnage des fonds
des saignées qu'il faut faire dans fonds
marins en fait c'est comme un chant
tient aux chantiers de travaux publics
sur terre ça va perturber énormément la
vie marine t d impact qui sont
irréparables quoi c'est surtout ça le
problème
s'ils touchent à la vie marine s'y
cassent des écosystèmes ça met des
années des dizaines d'années des fois à
revenir
des fois ça ne revient pas du tout
il distribue les millions à tout le
monde que ce soit les communes aussi qui
sont impactés par par la vision en fait
de ces éoliennes pour pallier à tous ces
impacts ils donnent de l'argent tout y'a
pas à discuter il les faut donc
taisez-vous on va vous est dommage et
mais on va les mettre
[Musique]
ils ont fait un tapis rouge pour
l'éolien et ça devient très clairement
ça devient très antidémocratique oui je
vous la corde sur dunkerque c'était déjà
un secteur en crise je pense que ce
projet finira d'achever le dernier
exploitant de son secteur